Let's start by celebrating our zip code of the day.
It's 33172 Miami, Florida.
(audience cheering)
Which I'm guessing has really nice weather right now.
And one of our local CBS affiliates, WFOR CBS4.
Miami was founded in 1896 by Julia Tuttle.
And she is the only women, woman, excuse me.
In the United States known for having founded a major city.
Go Julia.
Go Julia, exactly.
(audience cheering)
And with more than 50 underwater wreck sites
for SCUBA enthusiasts to explore,
Miami once was nicknamed Wreckreactional,
wreck-reactional diving capitol of the world.
Miami, Florida, I wanna hear from you.
Does anyone have time to put pen
to paper and send us some mail?
I'll open your letter.
All right.
In fact, we're gonna open our first letter right now.
Oh look how creative and cute it says,
oh my goodness, all right.
"Dear drew, I recently watched, 'Never Been Kissed'".
(audience clapping)
Thanks.
"Even though I'm not in high school yet,
oh, "two more years, I still really enjoyed it.
"I've a few questions I wanted to ask.
"Why did you want to play Josie
"and after playing her did you find
"a little bit of you in her?"
Well, "I love watching your segments with Jonah."
Oh, Maeve in Connecticut.
Maeve, the reason I wanted to do "Never Been Kissed"
was because we all have a little Josie Grossy inside
of us and we all feel awkward and we all wanna fit in.
And we admire a group of people
and wonder if we can see ourselves in it,
or if they'll let us in.
And we put so much value in those other people.
And along life, you learn that you have
to accept yourself and you'll find your pod.
(laughing) You really will in these days,
but you will find your group.
And so, yeah, there's me in her and her in me for sure.
And thank you for writing in, Maeve.
Oh and she sent me some leaves too, from her yard.
Maeve, I am into you.
(audience cheering)
I feel you.
And I'm gonna put this on my wall
and I'll send you a picture of it.
Okay, letter number two.
Oh, it's a gift.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, and Poppies, okay.
Oh, what is this?
What pray tell?
"Dear Drew, the other day I noticed you were having
"a hard time eating a bowl of soup.
"So I am sending a bowl cozy I made.
"Place the bowl inside of it
"and it will insulate your hands from hot or cold.
"I use mine when I eat ice cream."
Deanna Cox, Greenup, Illinois.
Deanna, all I can say is that you really see me
and my style and the next time we're in the kitchen,
please watch because I am gonna feature your bowl cozy.
Thank you so much Deanna, keep watching,
you're gonna see this and thank you for helping me.
(audience applauding)
Okay, our third letter.
Lemme move this.
All right, we have time for one more.
Gosh, Deanna.
Okay, "Dear Drew, I enjoy watching daily."
Oh, thank you.
By the way, I think you can see the Josie Grossy
coming out in me, I'm like (gasping).
"I especially love how you reach out
"to people who have unselfishly gone
"above and beyond by giving back and giving thanks."
Thank you for noticing that.
This show is really a platform for everybody else.
"And I wanted to tell you about Operation Troop Support.
"It was established in 2003 by retired Air Force
"Lieutenant Colonel Richard Moody, and his wife, Christine.
"They send care packages to our deployed troops.
"Unfortunately, when COVID hit all fundraising events
"to bring postage money for the care packages
"have been canceled and the cost
"to send a care package is $17.20.
"So if you can find it in your heart
"to help the American soldiers
"through Operation Troop Support,
"they would greatly appreciate it."
Charlene Potter, Danvers, Massachusetts.
Charlene, we appreciate our soldiers
and I thank them and we all do for their service.
So we're gonna donate a thousand dollars
so that they can get a little something
from home.
(audience cheering)
Thank you for bringing this to our attention
and anyone else out there,
if you would like a little advice,
a suggestion of someone or something we can support.
If you wanna see me try something, tell me a joke,
send a picture, email.
No, don't email me, snail mail me your questions.
Requests, photos, heartfelt funny stories,
just bring it.
I mean, look at Deanna and her soup cozy
and look at Maeve and her beautiful leaves.
I can't wait to read more of your letters
and thank you Charlene for bringing Operation Troop Support
to our attention.
Thank you so much.
Truly yours, Drew
(upbeat music)